bischoff est très triste parce que ça
c'est le point de vue médical mais vous
alors la tradition fout le camp ah non
pas du tout une fois je suis partisan
tout à fait de la structure il est
reparue moi je déplore le grignotage
mais absolument parler de ça le
grignotage la barre chocolatée de merde
à 10 heures du matin le cornec pommes
frites et que ça à midi ou le sandwich
de mauvais pain avec un jambon
polyphosphates et c'est ça qu'il faut
éviter à tout prix il vous remet mais
qu'on vous disiez ça lui mais monsieur
rentre et sort c'est bien de dire ça
mais dans les écoles qu'est ce qu'on
leur donne à manger ces pauvres mômes
c'est c'est bien gentil d'installer des
des écoles de goût pour l'éveil de
sensorielle du bamba les côtés ça marche
pour le moment ça marche dans la
circonscription du ministre qui est le
promoteur de l'opération c'est à dire
dans la région de loi à mon avis ça
c'est pas beaucoup déplacer en dehors de
ça mais c'est pas ça le problème c'est
que après avoir appris à faire la
différence entre la mer le salé le sucré
l'acide
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dans leur assiette
dans les cantines c'est là où il faut
agir c'est à ce niveau là
sinon ils vont dans les phase ii bat fou
parce que vous appelez ça des fast-foods
ça s'appelle des faces b comment vous
pouvez expliquer qu'ils y vos sens qu'on
les y pousse de gaieté de coeur et
volontairement mais parce que ça les
amuse pas si c'est divertissant parce
que c'est des trucs qu'ils ont pas la
maison vous voyez bien les membres
réclament des frites si on leur faisait
une fois de temps en temps comme si
c'était un cadeau qu'on leur dit va
manger ça pour avoir la paix donc si
c'est un mauvais rythme simple
[Musique]